[Music]
hey everybody
what's going on yeah monday i see that
bee's nest changed his name to murder
hornet's nest yeah
he's mad
murderer
he's light on cash he's getting mad
where's my money well like i said it's
it's almost christmas i'm light on cash
too and we just moved like not too long
i guess i'm still like kind of broke
from that and i may have to [ __ ]
close this house this month if they
[ __ ] start pressuring me so we have
to see oh and i paid the we paid [ __ ]
the rent
yeah the longer we're paying rent the
more money we're flushing down the
toilet it's better if we get that on the
down mortgage
that's true how it is yeah well try to
get some equity
in the house yeah
see if everybody's there they're all
starting to show up
got uh louis hernandez is in
um
yeah so we're going to talk about rock
and roll
[ __ ] love this movie it's pretty good
i love it pretty good and you can watch
it you can watch it free on youtube and
it's the publisher that actually put it
up because it
you can't get it anywhere anywhere else
and everything there's some kind of a
problem with the ownership of it they
own it but they can't market it or
something no well oh yeah i'll kind of
get into that because it's really kind
of shitty what happened to this poor
little movie because this movie's
[ __ ] rad i saw it a bunch on cable
back in the 80s like in the in the mid
to late 80s it's like a
a big long music video of [ __ ] real
cool 80s bands that has a story and it's
animated and the main characters are
rats
but they look like humans they've got
humans with little background noses
little brown noses
and there's a reason for that it doesn't
i mean if you think about it really like
the story
it doesn't have to be post-apocalyptic
you know like it doesn't have to be you
know humanoid rats or anything
but
there's a reason why it came about that
way too it's it's kind of a rock opera
yeah i so so like i said i kind of feel
like this was on cinemax or hbo or
something like that a bunch in back in
the day it came out in 1983
although they started working on it in
1978 so it took like a really long time
to come to fruition
it's actually canadian
uh it was done by nelvana which prior to
that they had only done kind of like
kids cartoons
and stuff
and uh this movie
oh oh by the way if you're not in the us
um this movie is actually called ring of
power
um
so that might be why like so if you're
in another country and you want to see
it it might be under that title instead
it's called um
rock and roll in the us and i'm pretty
sure in canada as well which is where it
came from all-star cast with the music
i mean blondie
yeah debbie harry uh does songs were lou
reed iggy pop cheap trick earth-winded
fire
um just a great and sadly again there
was no soundtrack album
and most of the songs have not been
released officially and they're good
real good yeah i think the cheat the
three cheap trick songs came out on some
box set that they did a few years back
um the iggy pop song
that's on there which i think is called
pain and suffering
that didn't come out until 2019 like is
an extra track on something that had
been remastered
um
angel's song
the debbie harry one she actually kind
of rewrote that a little bit like
changed the lyrics a little bit and did
another version of it for her album deaf
dub and blonde which came out of the 90s
i think but other than that like the
other songs i don't think got released
and that's like really
shitty because like the lou reed ones
were actually really good they're all
good all the songs are good yeah the
bloody songs are like hits they're
[ __ ] really good and if you i've
never heard them before i was like where
the hell why don't i know this song and
it's because it's only for this movie
but she released it later but i think it
was different it was a different version
yeah it had a different uh title yeah i
think it was i can't remember what the
title was but she changed the title yeah
oracle pointed out and alvana did an
interesting take on the devil and daniel
webster
or faust where the heroes were dan and
jan who were mice as well as musicians
and i was gonna say
that that is actually where the gem or
the germ of the idea for this movie came
about it actually came it's called the
devil and daniel mouse
and it was essentially a faustian story
about a band of humanoid mice or
animated mice and one of them makes a
deal with the devil to be like a famous
rock star it was made for kids they had
like a coloring book that went along
with it and everything like that
interestingly and i just found this out
today and this kind of blew my mind
do you remember the bauhaus song party
of the first part yeah i remember it
with it was just like an instrumental
and it had kind of like a it sounded
like film dialogue of somebody like it's
from that cartoon that's where that uh
that's where that sample came from which
i didn't actually realize i knew it was
from a movie or a show or something but
i had never heard it before
um but that's where it comes from okay
so when they first conceived this movie
uh back in 1978 1979 whenever it was um
as i said nelvana as a studio i think
they'd done like care bears and that
kind of [ __ ] so they did like kid stuff
and this movie was originally supposed
to be a kids movie too it was originally
called dratz
and it was about uh it was the same
thing it was it was post-apocalyptic it
was a band of you know you know after
the apocalypse and
rats and cats and stuff like that had
evolved back into humans
yeah uh and it was about a band and
everything like that but
as time went on
and uh more adult cartoons started to
sort of come to the fore like heavy
metal and you know some ralph bakshi
stuff uh some of the people in hollywood
were like well why don't you make it
more adult oriented
um so they started going more in that
direction yeah you were talking about
that this is for kids and i was like
yeah it is kind of but the tone is more
like heavy metal
yeah it's not as sexual it's not as
sleazy as heavy metal but there is
swearing in it uh there is violence in
it there is like some i guess like the
character of angel is a little bit
sexualized but it's not not really till
the end and it's not really
over it's not there's not nudity or
anything like that but there is you know
bad language and
violence and things like that so it's
not really i don't think it's going to
traumatize a kid for life or anything
like that but it's probably not it's
like an adult team a teen
yeah it's not super
it's it's not really geared toward kids
yeah not not as not as safe perverse as
heavy metal no first one not by not no
not by a long shot which i wouldn't i
wouldn't call it heavy males perverse it
just
can get kind of raunchy yeah it's rocky
yeah yeah so this is adult oriented but
not raunchy yeah
it just does have adult themes to it i
guess
um but yeah so
so kind of all that happened and it just
kind of evolved more into
a more adult story i suppose
now interestingly there are actually two
versions of this the original canadian
version
um one doesn't have
i think we were talking about this in
some other movies i don't know what it
is about american film distributors this
this movie actually for to be
distributed in the us it was picked up
by mgm like united artists they picked
it up for distribution but then they
were like meh and they didn't really
release it i think it was maybe i don't
even
know if they released it in theaters it
might have gone right to vhs or if it
did that because it only ended up making
like thirty thousand dollars in the us
and canada so it's like they didn't even
bother releasing it like they just threw
it on a shelf somewhere which seems
really weird
but
the american version
uh they had to put kind of a title card
at the beginning with a little bit of
narration
explaining
that it was post-apocalyptic and that
street animals like rats and stuff had
evolved back into humans so this is like
in the future
whereas like i said the canadian one
didn't have that and it doesn't really
need that i mean you'll figure it out
uh i think i did read like one
contemporary critic that was like why do
all the why do all the characters look
like they have dog faces
you know what i mean
but they're rats that's why they're all
they're all rats
um and the reason that they are all rats
was because the original idea they were
all mice so you know there you go
so uh the canadian version doesn't have
that uh you know the explanation and the
canadian version also has a different
guy voicing omar
um the voice was done by greg salada in
canada
but for whatever reason the american
distribution i've actually never heard
the canadian version because the
american distributors like well we want
an american actor that has more name
recognition
so they got uh paul lamat who had been
in american graffiti he was in the
burning bed he was in the puppet master
movies so he was kind of more of a name
so they got him to redub
all of omar's stuff the other voices
they kept the same
but i have to say one of my favorite
things about this well
like i said i've seen this movie
probably a million times uh i saw it on
cable i recorded it and every now and
then i'm just kind of like man i want to
watch rock and roll again it's just it's
so good it's and i i just it's a crime
what happened to it distribution because
it just disappeared even nowadays it is
a [ __ ] to get hold of you can watch it
you know you can watch it on youtube for
free which is good but if you want like
a real fancy
high res copy of it and all this other
stuff they did one back in 2005 that
actually had the devil and daniel mouse
on it and uh some behind the scenes [ __ ]
but it went out of print
uh so you can i don't think you can get
any more if you can it's really really
expensive it's gonna be some used
collectors out of yeah which that's
really shitty and i kind of i just kind
of feel like for a long time people were
like selling bootlegs of this at
conventions and stuff because you just
couldn't get it yeah and people were
like man it's so sad because it's really
really good and nobody really talked
about it um but other than like the
soundtrack for this being amazing all
the songs are amazing the story is cool
my favorite thing about this is uh don
frank's doing the voice of mock the bad
guy
uh don franks he did a lot of if you go
to his wikipedia page he's done like a
zillion things not just voice work he
does a lot of voice work i didn't
realize that was the same guy that
played the sheriff in the original my
bloody valentine
i didn't i didn't recognize his voice he
is so great as the villain
the villain's name is actually mock
swagger so he's supposed to be like mick
jagger but yeah he's kind of david
bowie-ish too
um and his singing voice is lou reed
mostly
but uh so yeah so the story about this
they're all rap people like i said it
doesn't matter but it's post-apocalyptic
so there's this little town like some
dinky [ __ ] town called omtown
uh whose one claim to fame is this big
uh what do you call like a power plant
now there's this band there uh comprised
of four people which is angel omar
stretch and dizzy
and they're kind of on the shitty
hometown circuit like they're playing at
the beginning in this club and there's
like two people there watching them and
they get cut off in the middle because
it's like you know they just suck or
whatever it's just like an open mic
night or talent night or something like
that now meanwhile uh the bad guy mock
is sort of this
he's a rock star um but he's also like a
magician he's a little mock the magic
man that's what they call him and he's
sort of like still popular
and legendary but kind of his
he's kind of star is fading a little bit
i guess because he says something like
oh my last concert was not completely
sold out you know what i mean so he's
kind of on the downward slope
so one thing he's decided he wants to do
as one does
is
summon a demon from another dimension
he's very lovecraftian
that is pretty much going to wipe out
the earth because he wants to get back
at everybody for not loving him anymore
pretty much
and uh for the spell to work
he needs this one specific
voice like it's a sound frequency
that will bring that will open the door
to bring the demon into the dimension
and destroy the world right
so uh it will surprise no one to find
out that mock has been doing this talent
search quote unquote looking for this
voice that will do it and it turns out
that it's angel's voice uh that will
bring the demon now she doesn't know
this obviously
uh so mock first tries to like sweet
talker
into
uh hey come join me leave these losers
behind you're just gonna be on this
crappy hometown circuit for the
australia piece i'm going to take you to
nuke york which is what they call new
york now obviously and uh you know
you'll be a big star and everything and
she doesn't really want to do it uh so
then he decides he's going to take her
by force
and there's kind of all this other stuff
going on where
he makes omar think that she went of her
own volition so he's basically like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] because there's kind of a
thing about
um
him not really wanting to share the
spotlight in the band with her like they
have a big argument at the beginning
like he wants to do his song she wants
to do her song and she kind of
takes over from him and he gets mad and
they have this big thing so uh so that's
how it goes on but they eventually like
get to a thing where they have to go and
save her uh from mock and you know stop
the demon from coming out of the
dimension so that's where the story is
so it's kind of like a sci-fi fantasy
type story
i don't know if i really want to spoil
it but i will say yes it's almost like a
new movie almost people people yeah
cause i feel like a lot of real
i don't know it's just it's really
it's one of those ones that just very
very sadly like fell through the cracks
if you like heavy metal the first one
you'd like this it's
in that same spirit
yeah and honestly the animation for this
i mean they had
300 animators working on this
um they spent so much time and money
working on this that it almost
bankrupted the studio yeah it's more of
a rock new wave angle
it doesn't have
not much metal in it uh
80s
it's good you know it's good it's just
it's got its own tongue it's neat you
know
yeah and as i said before it does not
have a horror angle no not really like
like heavy metal had
um
just slightly sci-fi post-apocalyptic
kind of but as i mentioned it's almost
like it doesn't have to have been
post-apocalyptic this could be happening
it could be happening anywhere it
doesn't really matter anywhere in the
80s yeah um you know but the fact that
it is that kind of gives the like the
backgrounds like a little bit of a blade
runnery yeah
this story kind of like phantom of the
of the paradise a little bit it is
actually it's a rock opera it's a bunch
of different rock groups in conflict and
working together and whatever the music
industry
yeah yeah definitely that got that kind
of a [ __ ] but i will say that
it didn't use because i kind of feel
like heavy metal has its own kind of
look to it where they use a lot of
rotoscoping and stuff
i think they used some rotoscoping in
this
but it took so long like to work on this
that
a lot of it is like traditional cell
animation and they used like some early
computer graphics one of the first
animated movies to do that as far as
like i'm aware and it actually um
for the time period the animation in
this is really nice it really really
looks like they took some time with it
and it looks really really good
animation is almost kind of like on par
with akira
if you remember see akira yeah japanese
anime was kind of like kind of like that
but american
maybe that's not a good comparison
but yeah it's good
yeah um mike barrett said apocalyptic
movies are hit and miss with me uh yeah
this like i said this is a
post-apocalyptic but it doesn't have to
be it doesn't really factor into the
story all that much yeah they're in the
future they're raps they've evolved into
humans
uh but it's still just like a human
story like in the human world
yeah i mean it might as well be there's
nothing 80s there's nothing different
yeah other than everybody looking kind
of like rat-faced and having big like
mouse ears yeah they're not ugly though
no yeah it's kind of like it could you
could say they look like mice too
well as i said if you try originally if
you see yeah if you see the um the devil
and daniel mouse
they looked more like
mice yeah but the more
that they went more in an adult
direction in a sci-fi fantasy direction
and less in a kid's direction they made
them look more human so basically most
of the characters look like humans
except they kind of have
muzzles a little bit
you know
yeah so you're in the future
post-apocalyptic future where
everybody's rats it's but it's almost
kind of like cyberpunk
yeah things look of the 80s
yeah and mike barrett also says heavy
metal 1983 oh that was 81 wasn't it
heavy metal uh i don't know i thought
that came out at 81. maybe it was 83 uh
i didn't care for yeah this but like i
said this one is not one this one's not
an anthology this one is just like one
regular story and i don't want to
oversell too much like saying oh it's
just like heavy metal because it's not i
mean tonally it's not like heavy metal
and it's not as sleazy as heavy metal
um
honestly i like rock and roll better
than heavy metal but that's just me
um
[Music]
i you know i don't know heavy metal is
good but i just some of the stories i
like and some of them i don't so it
seems a little more inconsistent yeah
this one i just like the idea behind it
i like the whole story angle i like the
demonic like love crafting thing i like
the visuals i like all the character
work um all the voice acting is really
really good especially don franks
who plays the villain he's just i mean
he steals like pretty much every scene
that he's in i mean just he's so
he's just he's so evil and like over the
top but he's also like really kind of
charming he has like this really
gravelly
kind of voice that's kind of seductive
at the same time but then he's but it's
just like it's a really really good
performance
um but yeah so
yeah so i don't i don't want to say
those two things are too similar but
i don't know it's a similar vibe i feel
like if you liked heavy metal you
probably like this as well even though
like i said it's not as raunchy
but
but it's not a kids movie either
you know
because i've liked some kid
you know kid-directed animation too like
secretive nim i was i'm really into that
and actually i just rewatched that a few
months ago and i still liked it and
which is that's definitely a kids movie
um
this one is a lot more adult than that
but it's not as
as sleazy as heavy metal is yeah heavy
metal came out in in 81. yeah i thought
it was 81. yeah i don't know
is there a 1983 version
nothing i know of there's just an 81
that was the original one and then there
was the 2000 one which we talked about
yesterday yeah no there is no 83
yeah so it was 81 maybe he just got
confused because this movie came out in
83. although as i said they started
working on this one back in the late 70s
it just took that long to get it off the
ground
um
oracle said i think they also did a
movie called halloween witch magic
also aimed at the kid market but it's
kind of trippy
oh now i kind of want to watch that yeah
it really i read the synopsis because i
haven't seen um devil and daniel mouse
but i read the synopsis of it
on wikipedia
and knowing that
knowing that that weird uh you know
sample
from the bauhaus song was taken from
that i'm like that i totally would not
have guessed that that was a kid's
cartoon
it really doesn't sound it doesn't sound
like a kid's cartoon so i guess they
were doing more uh
i've made canada man i feel like you
could get away with doing doing devil
[ __ ] in
in kids movies back then i don't think
you could have gotten away with that in
the united states not in the 80s because
everybody'd be like satan
oh my god everybody's ever been like
flipping out about it but it's just like
ah
whatever they're mice and that's they're
they're making a deal with the devil
it's fine it's for children
oracle says halloween witch magic
involves kids getting the local witch to
turn them into monsters for
trick-or-treating purposes
oh now see now i have to see that that's
a great idea
to get it to turn into like real
monsters it's like [ __ ] these fake ass
costumes we want to be real monsters
real holly and like scare everybody
that'd be like super cool but um yeah i
mean honestly
every song in this i love every single
song in this i love all the characters
in this
i mean
my my favorite one what i'm showing what
they look like oh okay they don't quite
look like rats they just that's angel
yeah yeah
yeah see they mostly just have like kind
of mousy noses like rat noses they don't
look like and they might do they have
tails
uh let me see oh i don't think they did
i don't think they did i don't think
they had two i don't think they did
for a second i was like no well some of
them did i think maybe um
mylar the guy that owns the club he
might have a tail but he looked a lot
more like a rat than some of the other
characters did she doesn't have it too
yeah
i think mylar had a tail
yeah so they basically just look like
people with noses
[Laughter]
oh oracle said the halloween which magic
is on youtube okay well i'm gonna have
to watch that because that sounds like a
delightful
and delightful idea
but yeah find
yeah that's yeah that's angel and omar
and that's mock in the background
so maki looks even less like
and he has kind and he has kind of fangs
is it
focusing yeah it's kind of
yeah he's one honestly i think that mock
bite might be my favorite
animated villain
of all time i know that's a bold
statement
but
i don't know i just really really like
his character because he's
um
he can do actual magic [ __ ] it seems
like
i mean obviously he can like summon a
demon and stuff because it does work
spoiler alert but
i don't know it's he's just such a great
i just i just love that voice
performance and i just like the way he
looks it's super cool and like i said
all the
you know all the music is great
um the lou reed songs he does the uh
my name is mock
song and then he does one that's kind of
more trippy called triumph
that's kind of like
that's the one where they
when mock gives them what they call the
edison balls it's supposed to be like
drugs it like hypnotizes them
and uh that's kind of the song that's
playing so it's like this really trippy
kind of uh song like that but i think
i don't know the debbie harry ones are
really really good
i mean
this song um send love through which
they do she does it at the beginning and
then at the end they do like a duet like
her and robin xander from cheap trick
and um it's just a great great song and
i don't think that was ever officially
released which is kind of shitty go look
for it um i mean you know like i said
you can watch the movie for free but
it's kind of sad that you can't get a
that you can't get a soundtrack because
there's such good [ __ ] music in this
even all the cheap trick songs are good
and i've never been a huge cheap trick
fan but
the first one that they do in the club
is almost kind of like almost sounds
like punk to be honest with you yeah
well cheap trick kind of had was trying
to yeah
that's true that's true yeah it's kind
of a pop version of it but
oracle said sorry the title is actually
witch's night out halloween witch magic
is the theme song
okay i'm gonna have to like watch that
okay so oscar perez says shitty movie
great couple and channel though so i'm
here are you talking about this movie
because who knows i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna have to argue with you sir i
love this movie i never get sick of this
movie and i've seen it at least 100
times as this is one of those ones that
i think i probably have memorized yeah
oscar comes up with all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] sometimes though he's oh that's not
a good mess and it's a [ __ ] great
movie
i don't i don't understand how you could
not like this movie this movie is a
delight from start to finish a lot of
movies enjoying a movie a lot of times
has to do with whatever [ __ ] state of
mind you're in at the time when you're
seeing it that's true
that's why
then you yeah
that's why a lot of times if i see
something and i'm kind of like meh about
it but i but the concept is interesting
i always will try to watch it again go
back later pick up on it because you
know a lot of times you appreciate it
more the second time but then if you see
it again the second time you're like nah
i still don't like it then that's fair
enough got my billy out of christmas
album today oh you did yeah she showed
up on there yeah you open it up the
inside has got uh billy's saying that
yeah i'm usually the christmas uh when i
have christmas parties i got to sing all
the music
at his house
so can you imagine he's like can i just
relax and have a christmas party he's
like i know he said he likes it
dance monkey's dancing
he he chose uh he chose uh his favorite
songs and he says what he liked about
him is that they're they're challenging
to sing
uh and he just does them straight
and uh but this is from a few years back
and it's been remastered
so the version i have
i'm very excited i just came out yeah
i'm excited about christmas just so i
can listen to billy yeah
it's called happy holidays
that's original yeah
he should have called it something like
um
[Music]
it's a nice day for a white christmas
something like that he could have called
it that might have been fun
i don't think he was trying to uh
gimmick it up he wanted to just go let's
take this just a straight a serious
christmas album right yeah with him i'll
tug on it
because he's always kind of he's always
to make that face he's like this is you
know patent pending but uh he doesn't
[ __ ] billy idle them up or anything
it's just
you know almost sounds like ben crosby
singing and [ __ ] sing it
well you know you got to respect that
and honestly i really liked the ones
that i heard yeah he does it classic
yeah that's pretty cool
but yeah so
uh if you're into animated movies if
you're into 80s music
uh
and especially like any kind of retro
old days mtv new wave type stuff and you
haven't seen this you have to [ __ ]
see it
it's just
and please don't tell me you don't like
it that'll just make me cry because i
love i love this movie i really do i
love it a lot and um
yeah i just encouraged them i know now
there's going to be like you stuck
you know because i know people are but
yeah seriously i love this movie and it
hurts my feelings they're asking if
you're going to do more java reviews
uh yeah i definitely will probably not
this i don't think i'm gonna do any more
this month because i'm doing all winter
movies uh this month but i will
definitely get back to you i have so
many i still have to do all the colors
of the dark i still have to do a house
with the laughing windows i still
there's so many that i still have to do
i have this huge huge list you guys
don't even know
uh but i will get back to them i promise
uh but yeah so i guess
that's probably it right
but yeah if you want to watch this movie
it's free and it's legitimately free on
youtube it's not it's not copyright
infringement as far as i know i think
it's actually the production company
that owned it actually put it up
there because it wasn't available
elsewhere back in the old days you had
to actually write to nelvana and go hey
make me a copy and they charged you 80
bucks and they sent you a vhs copy
because they had to do now the sadly the
original print of this movie
apparently got destroyed in a fire
so the ones they have now were just they
duped off the vhs
but it actually still looks pretty good
uh the one that's on youtube it doesn't
look shitty or muddy or anything yeah
they didn't have a laser disc
i know
you know
you guys don't know how good laserdisc
looked it looks so much better than dvd
it looked better blu-ray from the way i
remembered it
and that was honest that was on those
little crt televisions
but some of the definitions started to
get better on those crt televisions i
wonder what a laserdisc looks like now
on a digital tv
i don't know ask to do ask me dude from
uh from uh
uh it was deciding the record album
yeah i remember looking great i worked
in a record store in 1993 and we sold
although it never got really popular
they're expensive yeah i think we had
like two little bins full of laser discs
and i don't think the whole time i
worked there i don't think i saw a
single person buy one i saw um star wars
the first one i'm [ __ ] laser disc
blew my [ __ ] minds like seeing it in
the movie theater and the excalibur also
saw it on laserdisc a friend of mine had
a laserdisc it was just man i don't
think i've ever seen anything on
laserdisc what made it look good is a
part of it is that that in those days
the laser disc players and the
televisions and everything there were
thousands and thousands of dollars they
were big and they had great audio
so the speakers were [ __ ] great it's
like you're in a theater
i think it was like [ __ ] six thousand
dollar system
oracle said we have two laserdisc
players because my husband has the bond
double07 collection on laserdisc among
them okay yeah do you put can can you
put him on on a on a modern television
yes you can he can
convert the signal probably find a way
to fly well yeah like i said the guy
james from cena massacre he has a
laserdisc player oh and oliver harper
has one too yeah because he has he
really likes laserdisc so he has like a
[ __ ] ton of them
like one from japan and stuff i never
well you know i couldn't afford it
obviously yeah those rich people [ __ ]
that was rich people [ __ ] vhs was
expensive
yeah during that time that was rich
people [ __ ]
laserdisc was even more if you wanted to
buy a movie yeah
yeah they were like a hundred dollars
that's why everybody rented them for a
long time that's why there was such a
big like video story thing because it's
like well [ __ ] i can't afford to pay a
hundred dollars for a vhs at the rocky
horror picture show much as i wanted to
but you know you could rent it for three
or four dollars for a night or two
um
yeah
oracle said uh don't ask me how it works
it involved a lot of swearing from my
husband to set it up
trey says this is another one i've been
meaning to watch for years missed it
back in the day you should watch it it's
it's on youtube for free
watch it it's super fun i love this
movie and i love all the music from it
and i love the villain i just love
everything about it i've seen it a
million times and i just never get sick
of it i even wrote a big long blog post
about it a couple years back but you
know it's just it's really fun and it's
free so go watch it and tell me what you
think of it but don't tell me if you
don't like it because i'll cry just
kidding
um all right so that's all we have to
say for about this right yep all right
so we'll be back again should we do
another animated movie and just make it
a three-four
uh i can't think of another one well
we'll find something we'll find
something uh cause i could fail a day or
some [ __ ] like that oh my god that one's
so messed up or uh watership down
oh yeah that's on for free is it yeah oh
[ __ ] we should do that then okay yeah
we'll do watership down tomorrow that'll
be that'll be fun i haven't seen that in
a long time i read the book too there's
also oh the plague dogs which was kind
of a similar theme that is also free
because i think that's on 2b because
i've been meaning to like watch that one
too
uh so yeah we'll we'll do that one
tomorrow talk about the the scary bloody
bunnies
all right so thanks everybody for
dropping by and we will see you guys
again tomorrow